remember when you were in college
remember how smart you thought you were
how you thought yet it all figured out
and then you realize just how ignorant
you were the world slapped you in the
face with reality checking it to learn
your place and how to operate in it okay
now remove all that last part none of
that other stuff happened
you're just an ignorant college student
who's never lived in the real world and
now you're a congresswoman
Gavin McGinnis is not oh defend Gavin
calm is where people go right now to
defend you from the SPLC
right yes right and they can give you
some money right the best offense is a
good defense and a good defense means
mucho dinero
yeah we're going to be talking about the
green New Deal hold your thoughts before
we get to it okay question of the day
what part of Cortez is Alexandria is it
Alexandria cut Nina Pinta Santa Maria
yeah yeah what part of Cortez is green
new deal is your favorite was it was it
the eliminating air travel the farting
cows the complete lack of self-awareness
and drafting a bill whose language was
found once upon a time exclusively in
the lamentations of an insane person let
me know I have mine we'll go through all
of it I vote yes let's let's go context
first there's every we've been talking
about the beginning New Deal I think
you've talked about it quite a bit if
I'm not mistake it's the best thing for
Trump that ever existed that and
unfortunately the 40-week abortion they
term abortion a winning issue but now
they've turned energy into a winning
issue let's stand back let's take some
time off let's let them destroy
themselves one thing I will say
unfortunately been a lot of fake news
surrounding it there's been some real
news that the supposedly real news
claims it's fake news but then they
admit that it's real is if it sounds
confusing it's because there's no real
news so I'm gonna do my best to try and
separate fact from fiction I would say
their four main takeaways from the green
New Deal the first takeaway is the new
insanity baseline of the left the first
thing everyone noticed was that the bill
is terrible yeah yeah but it also reads
as if written by a crazy person maybe
because it was spearheaded by this crazy
person the world is going to end in 12
years if we don't address climate change
and your biggest
your your biggest issue is how are we
gonna pay for it and like this is the
war this is our world war two okay
Alyssa no do we have to pretend like she
sounds intelligent do we have to know we
have these no continue this facade
I don't like Nancy Pelosi I don't like
Hillary Clinton they don't sound
borderline [ __ ] sy is paying for it
in a revelant in detail I know okay say
the world is gonna end
how are we gonna pay for it that's a
really big detail it seems that's
something they wouldn't gloss over an
arm again yeah exactly
cuz if you can't pay for it guess what
the world's gonna end it by the way
according to its own faq summary the
green New Deal called for every single
building in America to be rebuilt
high-speed railroads to replace air
travel eliminate actual cow farts put
that in quotes because it's real this is
an air quotes it wanted to provide a
living wage job to everyone willing to
work but more importantly provide a
basic income to everyone unwilling oh
dear God and what's important about this
is when this is because people talk
about fake news and there was a lot of
fake news surrounding the story was yeah
when called on these facts Cortes and
the friends they claimed big news of
course then they just said what would
the wrong draft have been uploaded and
we'll get to more of that later so the
horrors of the disorganized rollout are
surpassed only by the ridiculous demands
in the actual bill it's as extreme as it
gets that thing people need to know note
that and I would encourage you all to go
read it but who endorsed it cory booker
Kamala Harris Kristin Gillibrand
Elizabeth Warren anyone else pretty much
everyone in the DNC which everybody's
gonna run for president potentially yes
exactly put my name put my name in the
corny Booker - again we're talking about
letting the left destroy themselves Cory
Booker went on this rant comparing the
green new deal to fighting Nazis and
landing on the moon there's something
here you go oh it's too expensive oh
it's all of this if we covered our
dreams that way we would have never gone
to the moon why they hate the wall first
from the scourge of not a totalitarian
regime
I really can't follow him he goes to the
moon and Nazis I don't know what they're
trying to do hooker is my least favorite
white person closely by his good friend
t-pain yeah maybe we should call you hit
notification bell if you haven't joined
my club lava scattering at comm / Mudd
Club because apparently subscriptions
don't mean anything on YouTube anymore
so notification about Mudd Club of
course subscribe on iTunes so you listen
the audio version
I think another takeaway that's really
important is this highlights the left
true agenda which is socialism the
greenie video is really not about the
climate it's about socialism the premise
of the bill is that it somehow benefits
the environment but something people
have been missing is that it
conveniently involves a tippy-toe toward
the government effectively seizing
private property and then rebuilding it
temporarily they're gonna give it back
oh of course they're trustworthy yes
this this is this is I don't know why
not more people of a now I sound like
Cortese I don't know why so few people
have been discussing this it requires
dramatically increased government
control of almost every industry from
the top down
think of it transportation farming you
name it government controls cortes
admits by the way the private sector
can't fund everything proposed she even
admits that the tax the billionaire
solution will not work for this that's
something that's important to note they
say oh you're you care more about the
money okay well where are you going to
get the money this is really the main
problem I think that people need to note
everyone else who's not a climate change
activists that we have with climate
change activists it's not really about
science it's about advancing socialism
now of course everyone out there can
acknowledge climate change to some
degree of course but people like Cortes
and burning the progressive left they're
not arguing about the science or even
about whether the government could fix
the problem
they're just huddle up asking how much
government control is needed to alter
your personal life in the environment
destroying habits they're not even the
point hold on a second how far are we in
the scientific trail yeah and how much
do we think the government could
actually do it's this is accepted the
only person who can solve this problem
is the United States government just how
far do we want to go yeah and that to me
is a very scary thought
so we did it hyperbole here replaces
science because the ends justify the
means that's what you're saying right
now with climate change alarmist so case
you forgotten by the way here's Cortes
claiming the world would
and in 12 years because of climate I
know you might have forgotten the world
is going to end in 12 years if we don't
address climate change and your biggest
issue of the left's deception right now
despite of course being endorsed by all
the top level Democrats how many pretty
much all of them green New Deal
rightfully drew a ton of criticism the
bill was so trashed that cortes I remove
the FAQ document by the way from the
website and they try to ghastly I have
one of the things that they never pushed
any these crazy agendas this happened on
Tucker Carlson her policy adviser
claimed the line about the unwilling to
work was something Cortez would have
never written and the Tucker was looking
at a doctored version this by the way is
a video that Cortes retweeted herself
yeah well we ever pay people who are
quote unwilling to work uh I we never
would write an AOC has never said
anything like that right I think you're
referring to some sort of document that
some I think some doctors document that
somebody said I did except she did and
you would and it's in your document
specific line is still available the
archived version I believe on her
website you can go check it out she also
picked like the least credible guy that
you could possibly pick to defend her on
their to pay he is working really hard
to trick us yeah and this is so
important to the Cortes push very this
looks like the bill continually claiming
the document had been doctored by
Republicans then pivoting a say there
was a draft that was accidentally leaked
here's the problem okay she released the
FAQ herself answered questions about it
all day and feel I even read an article
it was almost like an ask me anything
she didn't realize the FAQ was an
accident she didn't remove it from her
site until everyone who is not a DNC
candidate or official took a steaming
corn infested [ __ ] on this and by the
way the metadata for the PDF shows that
it was created and posted by God as his
chief of staff so she can't even
claimed that she didn't know what's
going on so this means one of two things
either a courtesan or equally googly
staff are far too disorganized to be an
any position of government authority or
be Cortes nor staff knowingly pushed
lies which given the continual nature of
the ethic seems much more likely see all
of the above it wasn't like once oh I
wish I could pull that back its let me
answer I'm willing to work yes
cow farts let me put in a good Act I
feel good about these choices I'm going
to keep making them why why am I talking
the fourth and final takeaway is when
you shine a light in the left I think
you see this from from this bill here
they scurry they retreat mr. McConnell
announced Tuesday they would call for a
Senate vote on the green new brilliant
they three Democrats completely free
market co-authored by the Green Deal
called the vote sabotage yes I don't
know how that works if the Senate
refused input open wooden Republicans
the accused of obstruction of course
yeah yeah they will be accusation
strikes let's go something could they be
that's exactly how what happened
Democrats will have to admit right now
that they are the party of a complete
socialism used to be veiled Mona Lisa
said well when you're saying socialist
you really wanna say the n-word or Obama
so it's a synonym it's just racism and
you use socials as a dog whistle you
want to apply that to Bernie you want to
apply you want to apply it to Booker
Warren to Cortez at what point to go no
listen you're just actual socialists
also by the way case you messy there are
people being in our streets yes non-stop
they say we're just gonna create an app
that lets you know where they're
continuing on the streets have you seen
that gonna be yeah hotels have maps now
that have this bum areas and bum used to
mean homeless man now it actually means
a person's buttocks in the bum areas of
San Francisco completely blacked out
because if you go there you will be like
Katie Hopkins was skating on people
matter like you slide like you're on a
hockey rink here's the deal there were
some false memes out there I think
that's important to note there were some
fake news pushed regarding the green new
deal
which is a shame because the truth is
enough read the bill read the archived
FAQ for yourself let me know what you
think this bill in and of itself without
any embellishment expose the actual
agenda of today's left by the way where
are the valiant media fact-checkers
Cortes under senior officials just claim
is fake news and no one calls them on it
no one more importantly the fact that
Cortez is now the face of the DNC for
many people and if the media just goes
along with it is alarming to the degree
let me paint a picture for you this is
why I think a lot of people on the right
can't stand Cortez and a lot of people
on the left love her but they can't
articulate it think back right now do
you ever when you were in college okay
remember how smart you thought you were
how you thought you had it all figured
out
then remember one year we had your first
real time like job in the real world
full-time job maybe when you got engaged
married maybe you had some kids and then
you realize just how ignorant you were
the world slapped you in the face with
the reality checking and to learn your
place and how to operate in it okay
now remove all of that last part none of
that other stuff happened you're just an
ignorant college student who's never
lived in the real world and now you're a
congresswoman spending other people's
money that's how this bill gets made
that's who portes is and that's who
could be in line for the presidency of
your country okay if you liked this
video you know you watch videos on
youtube if I were Jimmy Kimmel if I were
Stephen Colbert or Trevor Noah
I would tell you to subscribe but I have
no corporate overlords who demand that I
do this demeaning promo I do the
demeaning promo because I choose to
subscribe or hit the notification bell
because I need you I need you please do
it